Donald Trump has been disqualified in
Colorado the Supreme Court has ruled
that Trump under the 14th Amendment
cannot be on the ballot the first thing
that means is the GOP Primary ballot and
of course that will mean the general
election ballot now there's a lot going
into this the ruling is stayed until
January 4th because of appeals but that
is mean anything because they have 990
days I believe Colorado may be different
but typically you have 90 days to get
your your ballots in order for an
election and this means if they do not
have a resolution by that day the 4th
obviously they may actually print
ballots with no Donald Trump the
implications for this are very severe it
could it will jeopardize the GOP Primary
and that may be the key strategy here
Donald Trump has issued a statement
about this the ramaswami has vowed to to
remove himself and is calling on all
other candidates to do the same of
course the other more spineless
candidates likely would not and we've
got a lot of news a lot outside of that
as well we've got 12,000 migrants
crossing the southern Border in one day
Ashley stclair posting a video from the
airport from from an airport I believe
this was in Phoenix when she was at uh
leaving tpusa showing all these migrants
getting premium seats premium on
airlines to be flown all across the
country and of course there's a movie
coming
out it's called Civil War and they've
got a map of their breakdown of what
happens about about what happens to this
country so we're going to talk about all
of that before we get started my friends
head over to the best song ever.com
click download your price download the
song for at least 69 cents it's our new
song together again a cover from the
classic hit by Smoky Mike and the god
king you may know them as Michael nolles
and Jeremy boring when you do you will
also get a a promo code for 35% off all
cast Brew purchases only good for the
next week and a half or so this includes
subscriptions so if you download the
song you get the promo code and you
subscribe to any amount of coffee one
bag two bag three bag let's say you just
one bag of coffee coffee per month that
35% will hit every single month forever
get this even if you cancel the
subscription and you want to resign up
later you still get the 35% off that's
why you should go do it but also it was
a lot of fun we're uh we're building
cultural businesses we have this amazing
photo of Phil leonti as seen in the
music video of course with that striking
beard he's currently he's he's getting
there he's working on it but you know
that's how that's how he he's viewed in
the AI world so uh definitely uh support
our work download the song check out the
music video also become a member at
timcast.net out with like-minded
individuals and even call into our
uncensored show to talk to us and our
guest don't forget to also smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show right now everywhere you
can is the best way to support our work
joining us tonight to talk about this
and everything else is Joe Kent hey
thanks for having me back on appreciate
it absolutely who are you what do you do
so uh was in the Army for a bit retired
Green Beret and now I'm running for
congress out in Washington's third
congressional district right on well
this going to be great I'm glad you're
here especially uh providing an inside
look in politics as you've experienced
it and what you think going be happening
in 2024 will be interesting so awesome
to have you Phil leonti is hanging out
hello everybody my name is Phil leonti
uh lead singer of All That Remains very
failed musician anti-communist and
counterrevolutionary what's up Shane
what's up what's good I have not slept
since we left America Fest I'm exhausted
but it was a lot of fun out there got
this sweet shirt from my friends at
ultrafree it says defund Satanism I
think it's timely that's Drea de Mato
and Robbie Stabler pretty rad people so
it's awesome to be here and it's good to
see you again Joe good to see you too
yeah we left uh
amfest at uh it would have been around
you know like 10:30 Eastern Time MH we
got back in uh uh in the Maryland area
at 5:21 a.m. and that's when I went to
bed for which I woke up at 7:30 to get
back to work and I worked all day that
builds character I guess so if I look
tired in the thumbnail that's why I feel
fine but I probably look like I'm dying
I feel like I am it was worth it that
that show last night with Tucker was was
absolutely incredible was an honor and a
privilege to have him we got sege
pressing the buttons yo I am here uh
that was fun I really enjoy that good
flight back as well so yeah let's get
into it man yeah here's the here's the
big news ladies and gentlemen from
cnr.com
Colorado Supreme Court has disqualified
president Trump from GOP Primary ballot
now of course it's more than just this
if they're arguing Trump is to to be
removed from the primary Bel they're
also saying the general as as well scr
uh.com reports the Colorado Supreme
Court disqualified Trump from appearing
on the 2024 GOP Presidential primary
ballot Tuesday's decision comes after a
lower court judge in Denver ruled
against removing his ballot access quote
a majority of the Court holds that
President Trump is disqualified from
holding the office of president under
section three of the 14th Amendment of
the United States of the United States
Constitution because he is disqualified
it would be a wrongful act under the
election code for the Colorado Secretary
of State to list him as a candidate on
the presidential primary ballot now many
experts have argued this is a gross
misinterpretation the 14th Amendment
does not bar someone from running for
president it it's only related to
Federal officers which are individuals
appointed by the president or
representatives and Senators not the
president
himself the lawsuit has cited a neverbe
used Civil War air provision of the 14th
Amendment which we all know crew has
argued Trump summoned tens of thousands
of En W supporters for a wild protest in
DC and that racism and white supremacy
the same violent ideology that led to
Civil War in its wake the 14th Amendment
pervaded Trump's Insurrection and
movement surrounding it there's there
there's similar lawsuits being filed all
across the country several states have
already ruled no we uh uh judges we may
see these get appealed to the Supreme
Court and the same thing may happen you
know I thought it was going to be
Colorado now there is some important
there's an important distinction here
the Colorado Supreme Court ruling is
stayed until January 4th but that's
meaningless all this means
is by by saying Trump can't appear on
the ballot they're saying when it comes
time to print the ballot don't include
Trump's Name by claiming the ruling is
state is meaningless because they're not
printing the ballots right now the
question is if three months out from
Super Tuesday Colorado Donald they do
not resolve this Trump will not appear
and then guess who's going to win the
primary I'd imagine Ronda santz this is
going this has oh man you guys ready I
hope you have a trusty fifth by your
side because for those that are enjoying
a nice drinking game you're going to
need it but uh we'll start slow we'll
start slow I know you're all getting
ready but not yet first the GOP is going
to erupt into uh uh just bickering and
infighting like we've already seen I
mean one of the big stories out of last
night with Tucker was that Tucker
Carlson said the people who represent
the S online are some of the nastiest
stupidest and zero some people he's ever
seen it is apparent that uh the
Republican party is is not getting along
however most people support Donald Trump
and I'm not saying Republicans most
people when they remove him from the
primary and they and the RNC tries to
give the nomination to someone else I
mean this there's going to be a Revolt
yeah there there was a lot of people
that took issue with what Tucker said
about uh the disantis campaign and I've
seen some of it like the there are some
people on the the Dan campaign that have
been fairly nasty and stuff but there
were a lot of people that were really
upset that Tucker had the audacity to
you know point that point to to say that
he saw that or that that was his were
they all from the DeSantis campaign I
think they were well that's it's a lot
of fans of D santis but look when
Christina Pasha who is basically Ronda
santis is number two is personally
leading flame Wars against Trump's fans
yeah you've debased yourself you have
lowered yourself to that of a fan so if
like Taylor Swift and Rihanna's fans are
like arguing on Twitter neither Swift
nor Rihanna get involved and nor do they
care and that's basically what Ronda
Santa campaign has decided to be just on
on par with Trump's fan base instead of
trump himself so be it so be it but
removing Trump from the ballot is the
only way these people could win which
it's no surprise they've all made the
move to try win the nomination because
they all expect at least everyone except
for V they expect Trump to be removed
this would be a great opportunity for
them to prove everybody wrong and
recognize the moment that we're living
in and for them to say this is much
bigger than my political campaign this
is much bigger than the Republican
nomination Vivic let it off perfectly if
they all rally around right now rally
around Donald Trump and say hey this is
actually about preserving our Democratic
Republic that's what I think it's going
to take for us to actually win because
if we're divided I mean I I fought a
really hard Republican primary last year
uh and unfortunately came up short
because the Democrats don't play that
game if we fall for this this time and
we are not unified we're not just going
to lose the presidency I I'm afraid we'd
lose the entire country so I hope
everyone recognizes what time it is
right now and gets really serious they
don't it's the uh try to be optimistic
you know what we should do you know you
know the the the Minutes to Midnight
clock the Doomsday Clock they have we
should get one of those we called the
minutes of civil war ah there it is and
we we'll inch It Forward I I love this
I'm seeing a bunch of Democrats twe
meting in celebration and I'm just
responding being like I'm really glad
they did this because democracy is very
dangerous to our democracy right
democracy dies during the Democratic
process right yeah the number of people
on the the what you would assume to be
the
responsible reasonable left that uh are
going to jump on this and be like oh
well you know and make
excuses there has been no due process to
remove Trump from the primaries I'm not
sure what mechanism uh Colorado has is
is using I'm not sure what they're they
like redefined the law right they
defined it as it can be for for a
president that was what they voted on I
guess yeah I mean I I suppose but
there's no other like it's unprecedented
for someone to be you know he's he
hasn't been charged with Insurrection
Insurrection is a specific thing and
it's something that's outlawed I mean
outlined in the law like the there are
certain criteria that have to be met he
hasn't met them to actually have have
carried to be to been there there's
there's legis the legislative branch has
codified what Insurrection would be yeah
there's an Insurrection act yeah this is
this is but but let's address this
because everyone keeps saying the same
thing and I don't think there's a
definitive answer just yet but we have
this Trump campaign blasts Colorado
Colorado judges Who removed him from
2024 ballot vows to appeal to the US
Supreme Court as he should he has to and
a lot of people are saying but you know
that they do this and Trump will
immediately go to scotus and get it
overturned perhaps but also understand I
don't know if the Su Supreme Court may
be favorable to Trump perhaps I don't
know that the Supreme Court actually can
overturn this ruling yeah I'm I'm sure
you're going to get a bunch of people
screaming the ninth and 10th Amendment
this is not a general election held
under us constitutional rules this is a
private primary nomination process held
by a state in tandem with other states
to determine at a National Convention
who a private organization will choose
to be their nominee not a general the
Supreme Court may very well take up the
case and they may say we have no
jurisdiction over what a state
organization is doing as it pertains to
a private organization's nomination
process imagine if someone was running
to be the captain of the bridge club and
there was some Tom Foolery about and the
bouts were you know screwed up and then
someone I'm going to I'm going to go to
the Supreme Court over this they'd be
like we don't care about your private
organization's leadership structure
right mhm I don't know the Supreme Court
can intervene in a primary yeah and even
if it was Federal the the Precedence
isn't really great I mean the Texas case
where Texas attempted to sue all the
states where there was discrepancies in
the election that never even got into
the Supreme Court so I mean this is just
law even if Trump can get it into the
Supreme Court they're just bleeding him
out they're making him expend resources
that no other candidates having to
expand and they're also beating it more
into people's heads Insurrection
Insurrection 14th Amendment and then
those of us that are you know in the
news every day will say no but actually
he's never been charged he's never been
convicted but all people are going to
hear who are suable is they're going to
hear oh Insurrection man he must have
been guilty of an Insurrection but look
the worrying thing and the reason why
everyone should uh um get ready with
their fifth uh uh maybe maybe Jack or
something is
because when you have what is Trump
polling at 2.3 up in aggregate across
the country you can say Trump is an
insurrectionist but the average person
is not accepting that no matter how many
times they scream it the average person
in this country the majority not even
the plurality support Donald Trump so
you run the risk of ripping this country
in half now I'll give you some
predictions Colorado removes Donald
Trump from the primary several other
states follow and they even make
reference to Colorado and other states
Trump gets removed from the primaries
they don't need to worry about the
general election yep Ronda santis and
Nikki Haley end up neck and neck Ronda
santis wins you now have what a 2024
four-way
race probably not Biden maybe let's say
Biden RFK Jr Trump and DeSantis all
running so perhaps what would happen
then
is no one gets 270 electoral votes it
goes to house delegations it goes to
Donald Trump let's say that Donald Trump
is removed from the ballot in Colorado
but but still ends up winning the
nomination that I think Colorado has as
of 2020 like 1.6 1.7 million Republican
voters what will end up happening is if
numerous states that are blue we don't
expect Trump to win anyway remove him
from the ballot Trump will win the
electoral college with 50 60 million
votes and Joe Biden will have 75 or
whoever or Nome Trump will win the
electoral college becoming president the
media will then say the Electoral
colleges archaic and broken how can we
have a president when he had 20 million
less votes the average person who
doesn't pay attention has no idea why
that is they will simply be told people
didn't vote for Trump when the reality
is you couldn't if you wanted to than
what happens to the sentiment in this
country the people who support Trump
Won't Back Down the people in Colorado
who support him and want to vote for him
but who can't will still keep supporting
him this how I think we inch towards uh
Civil War it's why it's so dangerous I
mean if you love this country and you
want this country to remain as it is and
continue on our path towards progress
like having the judicial branch step in
and say no we're going to decide who's
on the ballot it's incredibly dangerous
and I I think think the Democrats just
don't care they're willing to burn down
the entire system right now just to stop
Trump from coming back office they're
ready for it to go to the Supreme Court
like I can already hear them screeching
about Clarence Thomas and his wife like
if it goes there like they've got that
ready to go you know so that's like an
invisible landmine that they just they
plant all these weding for the it to go
that way what happens when without
legislation come August or uh July of
2024 I don't know inserts insert State
Arizona
just says look we've gone over it we
think Colorado was right Secretary of
State just says we will not be including
Donald Trump on the ballot for the
general election based on what we've
seen across this country the rulings are
clear blah blah blah sue us and then
they print the ballots without Trump
yeah every single activist uh you know
Justice right now at the at the state
level every single activist judge
they're licking their chops right now
they want to be the next ones to do this
and this is just blazing the path
Arizona loves doing it yeah
W Co States let me just say um I fully
expect every single Trump supporter to
not only agree with what I just said but
actually take it a step further they you
you should be thinking I'm wrong because
I'm not going far enough as to what the
Democrats are going to do if you truly
believe that 2020 was stolen from Trump
in The Most Extreme Ways with you know
you know Ian talks about flipping votes
even that can be done through hacking
voting machines and fraudulent ballots
then you better damn well believe that a
secretary of state banging a gavl
figuratively is the first thing they do
mhm if you think fraud is on the menu
the first thing they do is just erase
Trump's name and say sue us and while
you're suing them they'll be doing who
knows what yeah getting ready for phase
two I mean look how tight the margins
were in the in the key swing states
where Trump maybe lost 2020 I mean we're
talking about 12,000 votes 10,000 votes
in just a couple places so all it takes
is a few Secretary of States or even
County Auditors just to whoopsie and not
have Trump on the ballot they can say
look we confused like he he an
insurrectionist right 14th Amendment and
then there you go yeah we thought it
would have agreed I mean I don't know
what what were you doing media said it
over and over again yeah exactly I was
listening to like CBS ABC all those
types of places on the way in and they
just they use Insurrection with a
certain tone there's no no Nuance to it
whatsoever they're in another dimension
completely and and the people who listen
to them unless it's like someone
listening to them to see what their
point of view is which I'm sure there's
some like me and other others of us they
buy into that that Dimension oh go no
good this is fascinating well get into
it in a little bit but you know Donald
Trump recently had this quote where he
was referring to Democrats poisoning the
blood of this country through their bad
policies principally immigration and you
get all of the media screaming Trump is
now like Hitler because Hitler wrote in
minec blood poison and things like that
the funny thing is the people being
pulled in urban Democrat strongholds
overwhelmingly agree with Donald Trump
yeah they're they're they're outraged
over the migrant problem now again I
we'll save the migrant stuff because we
do have a bigger subject on that but I
just want to point out the media is
acting like the American people don't
matter at all right it's almost as if
the corporate press realized you know
what we no longer convince people let's
just keep saying the same thing knowing
they don't believe us and who cares the
Deep state will come in with the with
the boot and the Iron Fist and we'll do
what we want anyway yeah the the
corporate press also talks about the
Republicans who are for these types of
things with Trump and like they so they
make it so the audience believe like oh
well the Republicans think it's good too
but it's the establishment cronies you
know who are into that and yeah they
don't they don't want you to have any
they don't want you to question
narrative whatsoever let's jump to this
uh next component of the story from raws
alerts running candidate v g ramaswami
has pledged to withdraw from the
Colorado GP primary unless Trump is also
allowed to be on the state's ballot
additionally has demanded that Ronda
Sanz Chris Christie and Nikki Haley do
the same immediately Bravo good sir
commendable he is basically just laid it
down I mean this is this is he's he's
he's he's you everyone's before they can
blink
he's making that that chess play now Ron
Chris Christie or Nikki Haley who
remains I bet their polling drops I bet
people look at them as dishonorable for
this well look you you don't have to
like Trump but there's going to be a lot
of Republicans who are upset they don't
get a choice yes you're being told by
Colorado you don't we don't care what
you think you don't get a right to
choose the is standing up and he makes a
really great point in this long Twitter
thread the tweets this is what an actual
attack on democracy looks like in an
unamerican unconstitutional and
unprecedented decision a cabal of
democrat judges are barring Trump from
the ballot in Colorado having tried
every trick in the book to eliminate
president Trump from running in this
election the bipartisan establishment is
now employing a new tactic to Bar him
from ever holding office again the 14th
Amendment I pledge to withdraw from the
Colorado GP GOP Primary unless Trump is
also allowed to be on the state's ballot
and I demand that Ronda santis Chris
Christie and Nikki Haley do do the same
immediately or else they are tacitly
endorsing this illegal maneuver which
will have disastrous consequences for
our country today's decision is the
latest election interference tactic to
silence political opponents and swing
the election for whatever puppet the
Democrats put up this time by depriving
Americans of the right to vote for their
candidate of choice the 14th amend was
part of the Reconstruction amendments
that were ratified following the Civil
War it was passed to prohibit former
Confederate military and political
leaders from holding High Federal or
State office these men had clearly Taken
part in a rebellion against the United
States the Civil War that makes it all
more absurd that left-wing group in
Colorado is asking a federal court to
disqualify the 45th president on the
same grounds equating his speech to
Rebellion against the US and there's
another legal problem Trump is not a
former officer of the United States as
that term is used in the Constitution
meaning Section 3 does not apply as the
Supreme Court explained in free
enterprise fund public Company
accounting oversight board in 2010 quote
an officer of the United States is
someone appointed by the president to
Aid him in his duties under Article 2
Section 2 the term does not apply to
elected officials and certainly not to
the president himself the framers of the
14th Amendment would be appalled to see
this narrow provision intended to Bar
former US officials who switched to the
Confederacy from seeking public office
being weaponized by a sitting president
and his political allies to prevent a
former president from seeking reele
our country is becoming unrecognizable
to our founding fathers has there ever
been a time when someone was prevented
from being on a ballot in American
history I can't think I don't think it's
ever been used yeah I mean maybe not in
any legitimate like large scale kind of
way you know maybe there was some like a
criminal was trying to do something and
then they made a filing of I don't know
I'd imagine it think the 14th has been
used yeah not the 14 I could be wrong
I'm sure somebody on the internet on
fact check us I this stat by Vivic is is
fantastic and how fast he put that out
not just considering how much length and
and information he put in there is great
but in in politics a lot of times you
get told hey wait don't come out right
away let's test this let's see if this
is going to work out you know maybe
Trump going to take it off the ballot
it's going to be good for you let's give
it a couple days I I think this is
pretty genuine he just fired off right
away and said the stakes are too high
let's all rally around president Trump
let's rally around us actually having a
democratic process I I think that's
awesome for him and I think that's the
right way forward he he did this when
Trump was about to go get handed in to
to New York you know he came out right
away on the phone in the back seat right
and no one else did anything that was
when I was like thought the santis is
really weak and for this and for this if
Trump for some reason is completely
unavailable the is next in line not
Nikki not Ron not Chris Christie because
V has outright said I will step aside
yeah if they keep playing these dirty
games yeah and it's and it's it's it's
it's a brilliant move let's say in the
end he removes himself from the GOP
Primary and no one else does let's say
then something happens to Trump he goes
to jail and he's for some reason unable
to do it Trump supporters will select VI
over anyone else yeah because of his
willingness to stand behind Donald Trump
100% yeah I don't see how like if V
removes himself or whatever if Trump and
V are removed from the running I feel
like that's a win for the establishment
sure there's going they start something
else I mean a full moose party that yeah
that's possible too but that I that
would split and I I mean how it split
ends up splitting up you know is
anyone's guess um but I don't think that
it would be a positive right now because
they're taking Trump off the off of the
uh primary the primaries and stuff um I
don't know I mean maybe I maybe they
could start another uh you know another
uh party could I'm just going to call
bulm for now right and then Republicans
and then we got Kennedy doing his thing
independent and then the Democrats like
it should be interesting if they do it
the Bull Moose Party did not do well
though no un they third parties never do
I mean the libertarian party's been you
know struggling for decades that
actually would be really funny if
somehow Trump ends up the libertarian
nominee and then the Libertarians get
like 43% of the vote and it's like well
the Republicans are gone just that's it
don't worry the Libertarians hate
themselves they hate everybody so they'd
hate Trump plenty but I would think if
the 14th amember could keep him off as a
republican it could just keep him off
WR in in the general election yeah has
that ever happened has has ever been
like a massive write in for a candidate
not at the presidency there's like six
or there's like six or nine states that
you can't write someone in I forget what
Colorado one of them I'm not sure but uh
someone was tweeting about it I
retweeted it but there's like something
like nine states where that you can't do
a write in so that means likely you know
if he's not on the the ballot that he
can't win um at least if he's on the
ballot as a as a Republican right I I
just don't see I mean I don't understand
like I said first of all I don't
understand the mechanism because he
hasn't been found guilty of anything and
I feel like unless you matter does it
apparently it does got rid of Santos
like that too yeah I mean that's yeah
Mendes is is stuff in gold bars and his
in his well but he's not even he's not
even convicted no issues there what he's
not even convicted I this the point we
can all sit here and be like yeah Sandos
is a bad dude but he wasn't convicted
exactly and and due process doesn't
matter apparently to the Democrats this
is clear and I I challenge any of my uh
left leaning or or even left liberal
friends to give me a reason as to why
the Democrats do believe in due process
seeing as you've got Santos and this
situation with Trump I don't see any
reason to believe that anything that
they say about due process means
anything at all to them so and I don't
know what that means for the you know I
obviously I don't know what that what
that means for the country this is
unprecedented it's you know to toally
new territory it's clearly purely
political it's about an outsider who
challenges The Establishment whether or
not you like Donald Trump is irrelevant
it's about an outsider that the
establishment the established order
disapproves of and they're doing
whatever they can to make sure that he
can't get back into into office in you
know in you know in opposition to what
the people seem to want he is leading
the polls and they're removing him this
is to call this you know Banana Republic
stuff is insufficient the dude is
walking into like stadiums yeah exactly
cheered for and the only reason there
hasn't been some kind of more action
from the public is because because of
how comfortable Society is now I really
really believe that because life is so
comfortable not necessarily easy but
comfortable and people are so sedated on
whether it be you know whether it be
Pharmaceuticals or booze and smoke SM
and weed and all those things which look
I'm not judging anyone that does I have
I have plenty of history of all kinds of
substances and stuff like that so I'm
not dogging anyone but because of those
things life is easy life is comfortable
and life is a little on the numb side
because of that people aren't looking
for it's like a I've been saying it's
like a pandemic of complacency yeah
nobody wants why why do you life is even
a rough life in the west is a good life
and it's an easy life so why do you
really want to go ahead and unless
and this is probably going to upset some
people but unless you are actually
mentally ill which is what the left
seems to the more extreme left seems to
go after because those people are the
ones that are the revolutionaries
they're the people that are upset that
well this is scientifically proven
actually there's a higher higher density
of mental illness along those among
those who identify as uh left leaning
and so those people go and throw you
know mop cocktails at cop cars and for
some reason we ignore that and and just
say that's and also say a lot of them
not of them but a lot of them don't have
kids and don't feel this type of urgency
to save the future for children right
it's all like the luxury like modern
luxury complacency and stuff like that
so think about when it's the far-left
going insane and burning things down and
the children grow up in the Society of
violence and Chaos think about the
things they will value when they get
older they're not going to like these
people they're going to remember the
horrors that they experienced they're
going to remember their family members
killed and they're going to they're
going to understand struggle and pain
and they're probably going to be more
conservative yeah probably I mean the
data is already there I've said it 50
billion times mhm the conservatives just
have more kids now you take a any kid
you take a you take the the child of
liberals and you introduce them to a
world where the farle is burning and
destroying everything these kids are
going to live like rabbits little
tightly wound balls of stress and
anxiety and they're going to despise
living in that world I hope that's the
positive outlook and I try to be
optimistic but it's also they could
inherit complete nihilism and not even
know any better it might take much
longer for them to understand you know a
moral Center in a lot going
unfortunately be a lot of pain between
now and that's the and also like how
what kind of establishment gets put in
place of the liberal establishment that
the Democrats are literally trying to
destroy I don't care you can they can
give all the lip service they want to
democracy they don't give a sh crap
about democracy at all and they
definitely don't care about liberalism
they've been they've been wearing
liberalism like a like a skin suit for
ages so what kind of government what
kind of
of structure does it take and and it
seems that the structure is going to be
more racist less Fair it's going to be
less focused on economic growth and more
focused on it seems like it's going to
be focusing on shrinking the not just
the economy but shrinking the population
because we've got people that are so
concerned about um what in my opinion is
is climate alarmism all of these things
mean a a future that is significantly
worse than our recent past at the very
least possibly significantly worse than
any of the horrors of the of the 20th
century because if you're doing degrowth
you end up with if you end up with
population collapse you have a like we
talk about a a crisis of Competency now
when you have a a population collapse
there are entire industries that
disappear that's how you lose knowledge
because no one learned how to do it from
the people that do that do know how to
do whatever the topic is and then when
those people die that information is
lost the OR at the very least the skill
to do it well is lost it's all gone this
is the funny thing about people who harp
on conspiracies about the moon landing
and stuff questioning how do we lose
technology he looked at me real quick I
don't know if everyone saw oh yeah did
look at me it's fascinating that like
you know where's where's your you had a
laptop everyone listening you had a
laptop five 5 years ago where is it go
through all the files go through your
tax documents where your tax forms from
last year do you remember I know a lot
of you probably do a lot of people don't
and then they try to log in every year
going what was my pin and they're typing
away and they can't get in you know look
you you can't even remember where your
tax forms are you're going to remember
where some obscure document about
radiation shielding is from 40 years ago
good luck we the the population degrowth
stuff is basically we talked about it
with Alex Jones on the show when he was
talking about isil the gorilla and you
know they they want people to return to
a living in the wilderness kind of
Lifestyle I mean to be fair Tucker even
said he didn't think technology was
helping us the other day MH he said you
know explain to me one technology that
made people happy or something to that
effect well essentially showed the
regime that as long as you keep the
Netflix on and as long as people can get
enough money to go to the store and buy
their favorite foods they will take a
obscene amount of Oppression that I I
never would have thought was even
believable dud look at look if you can
guarantee sunny days you can absolutely
abuse your population look at what
people do in put up with in California I
mean I would go out there periodically
I've been out there a few times this
year and it is absolutely beautiful all
of the freaking time it's all it's
absolutely gorgeous all the time it's so
nice that the the government can just
absolutely abuse the population it's
super expensive taxes are ridiculous
they they've got you know obviously
you've got homeless population I saw a
video the other day
from 10 years ago of when Gavin Nome was
the the uh the mayor of San Francisco
swearing up and down that he's going to
clean up the homeless people a decade
later it isn't any better in in San
franisco it's literally spread to the
rest clean it up when she show up
exactly but that's the thing the the the
it's it's so nice if you get up and when
you wake up every day and it's
75° 350 days of the Year you'll put up
with a lot of crap I want to pull up
this story from polygon can Alex
Garland's Civil War somehow be a
political a bipartisan California Texas
alliance is certainly out there I
actually don't think so in the initial
trailer when we when we uh saw the brief
map showing the breakdown of what this
movie thinks Civil War would look like
we said it's it's absurd we didn't have
the full details we're getting a little
bit more details and now it's starting
to make sense as to what their vision of
a civil war could be pogon writes X Mock
and a director Alex Garland looks like
he will try to do the impossible of this
new film Civil War when his new film
Civil War hits theaters in 2024 depict a
second Civil War in which the US without
directly engaging with the politics of
why the war is taking place wait okay
I'm sorry depict a second Civil War in
the US without explaining why it's not
hard to see why Garland might want to
avoid thorny connections between the
movie and the very real politicians and
political groups blah blah blah that
said it's still audacious to try to
remove of politics from even a fictional
Civil War a fight typically born out of
political disagreement that can't be
resolved by either means besides open
conflict whatever disagreement is at the
heart of the conflict which the first
trailer carefully avoids pinning down
puts California and Texas in the same
boat which sounds Unthinkable at the
present moment and for that reason a map
graphic created based on a trailer has
obviously gone viral well here it is and
I actually completely agree with it and
uh I completely agree with this
depiction of what uh they believe a
Civil War in the United States might
look like now the the the movie trailer
that we've seen so far we don't we don't
know the movie but we'll see the movie
but uh ignore the movie and let's stop
and go back to Colorado removing Donald
Trump from the ballot what this could
lead to and why it could lead to or be a
component of what causes Civil War I do
not believe that Trump's Rock Solid 40%
support would ever abandon him if the
way he is stopped is through illegal and
unconstitutional me measures and dirty
politics if Trump
you know announc he was retiring people
would be angry they'd say no oh but they
would be angry with Trump and they try
and find someone of a vake if the
Democratic party uses obscure
interpretations and and and novel
interpretations of the law to remove
Donald Trump and then tries to hold an
election without Trump after even one
state removes him the likelihood of some
kind of civil conflict becomes
substantially more real so let's take a
look at this map Republic of California
second Republic of Texas when you look
at this map of itself the vision of what
could happen to this country actually
makes a lot of sense in the film they
mention that the what do they call it
the uh uh the California Texas alliance
or something like this the Western
forces are heading towards DC you have
the Florida Alliance this is their map
from the
film let me let me break it down for you
what I think is going to happen in this
movie so there is some kind of political
disagreement resulting in what appear to
be the blue States breaking off I'm
sorry remaining loyal and uh I backwards
and the red states are breaking off it
the the view of this film is that the
more conservative areas are the ones
that are going to secede for some reason
so of course you end up with northern
states which lean red and to Washington
and Oregon because they are very red
outside of the Cities they go Western
forces they outside of the United States
the Florida Alliance is the is the
traditional traditional South minus uh
uh South Carolina North Carolina
Virginia but of course this is much this
is Southern this is more conservative
leaning Texas well they were their own
Republic so they secede and say we're
doing our own thing California has the
calexit movement they say we're doing
our own thing so what is a Texas
California Alliance it's it's just that
it would be like the US and the UK
aligning on a military operation we
don't share a government you can make an
argument about NATO I suppose but we
don't act share an active government
Texas and California aren't actually fun
under one president they're in an
alliance to prevent the old United
States from taking over their states so
Texas says we don't care for the way you
live your lives California California
says we don't like what you do Texas we
both agree we do not want DC to send
their troops into our territory and take
us over so we'll work together Western
forces and Florida Alliance probably
agree politically but are split by
states that are in proximity to deep
blue and more heavily controlled uh uh
uh loyalist territories I think the
other other thing to consider that we
don't see in this movie is the the
potentiality of where military bases are
and where uh Weaponry is stored which
could result in the current you know the
States you see being loyalist or uh uh
having suceeded there's basically what
we got five factions in this based on
everything we're seeing now I don't know
what you guys think but I think it's
plausible yeah I New York you know I
grew up in New York and most of New York
is also red though you know I feel like
cities would seced or is so deep blue
and it's it's so population dense it
makes sense that these states are are
are locked in I mean obviously
Pennsylvania is purple and and Ohio is
purple West Virginia is 86% Trump
supporting but small population yeah
they look if anything happened the first
Civil War what happens to Maryland
Maryland's a slave state yeah with
tremendous Confederacy sentiment so
Abraham Lincoln says just start
arresting the politicians and they
that's what happens they round up like
was like 30 or so between 20 and 30 uh
State reps from Maryland just because of
their political views lock them up you
know one of the things that that
happened with the with the LA you know
the Civil War that happened in reality
like they were trying to secede what
happens if like there's not really a a
movement to try to secede there's just
like the the political Strife that we
have because again we've talked about
how the you divide in the US goes right
through Grandma's Kitchen you know it's
not not Regional anymore so like what
what does it mean
to and and but it wasn't what it wasn't
the fir the first American Civil War was
not Regional Maryland Delaware were
slave states and and they're north of DC
there was still there was still clear
there line I mean okay fair North and
the South Mason Dixon line but but the
point the point is it was the the
political sentiments were divided
Maryland Delaware slave states north of
DC had no choice but to be in because of
geography MH I mean and that's and
that's a technicality Virginia and I I
believe North Carolina we like we are
not interested in Confederacy when the
first secession wave happened yeah and
then the war starts and then you start
to see sentiment shift again so what is
I guess I'm I'm I'm trying to
conceptualize what it would what it
possibly could look like you know
without the secession of you know States
because I don't know that there's going
to be like any other civil war you you
don't need a you know back then I I love
this line because not only was it in
National Treasure and Nicholas Cage is b
day f um I don't know politically I'm
just saying I like his movies great uh
but there's there's a line where they
say this is true I I I I read about it
before the Civil War people would say in
other countries or in this country the
United States are yeah after the Civil
War it was the United States is it was
one country so so at the time a state
seceding was like it would it's like
brexit yeah you know now we wouldn't see
that because people don't view these s
these states as Sovereign Nations unto
themselves they view them as just
regions of a country it would look more
like Syria or Spain or or any other
traditional Civil War we've seen
throughout history before the United
States uh entered its Civil War but I
think a really great example of what you
can expect is actually in this map from
this film how is it that Washington and
Oregon are part of the western Force es
when you have Wyoming Idaho Montana I
mean these are Utah these are these are
more rightl I uh not Iowa but uh these
are more right Ling but hold on
Minnesota Minnesota is fairly Democrat
it's because conquer you will have
powerful military forces in certain
areas lot of weapons in Montana and they
decide these are the territories we
control and they expand and lock up
control of these states that's it Oregon
Portland and Seattle as far left as you
can go someone made the point on social
media they expect the narrative to be
that the Western forces immediately
captured and occupy Portland and Seattle
and the city it's the ruins of Portland
after the Civil War is just absolute
chaos with farle forces it's already
pretty ruined right now yeah now add
farle with machine guns you know
fighting with Western forces trying to
lock up the coastal region yeah I mean
that what kind of scares me about this
is that politics is Downstream from
culture and right now we've got really
heightened tensions that one a court
just came in and said hey we're going to
take away your Democratic process so
tensions are running High the regime
always kind of does these two for ones
where maybe the the court case will work
they'll get Trump off there or maybe it
will fail in court Trump has to expend a
bunch of resources a bunch of people get
really really mad and do or say
something that then allows them to turn
the full scope of the National Security
State on them Biden's already said that
Trump supporters are the number one
threat to National Security so the whole
state apparatus is already tooled
towards going after people who disagree
with the
I would say everybody chillot harvesting
don't you want to watch the watch the
but we should encaging people follow
Ram's lead unity and stay focused on the
actual goal it's worth pointing out that
a Green Beret is telling you that yeah
like the guy that the guy that has has
been trained to go into countries and
destabilize them and and train local
forces how to fight I've seen a few
Civil Wars and most of them are still
ongoing and most of them are pretty
horrible I mean between Iraq and Yemen
and Syria like it's nasty stuff and
people might say they want that when
they're frustrated but it's nothing we
ever want to see here to some degree do
you feel like like as I'm having
flashbacks thinking of what lockdowns
were like in autonomous zones and people
being murdered and fires right like I
feel like we're kind of there already to
a degree we during the yeah for sure
during the riots I mean the Chaz was a
real thing in Seattle they there was a
warlord they killed Mur where was your
first deployment as a Green Beret Iraq
Iraq yeah yeah Iraq in ' 03 so I I got
there we took Saddam um Saddam ran we
didn't get him initially but the regime
kind of fell and there was kind of a
calm and that's when we really started
messing things up uh when we fired the
entire bath party and drove that Rift I
mean just watching that break out and
and at first it was all just channeled
kind of against us and sort of the Iraqi
government but as we got into 2006 2007
when the Iraqis were really at each
other's throats and that's still ongoing
to this day like that when they stopped
targeting us and started targeting each
other and every morning you'd wake up
and you'd see people with their hands
tied behind their back with bailing wire
their you know hands swelled up like
Mickey Mouse balloon I mean just like
horrific stuff and this was like
neighborhood by neighborhood and these
people had one point in time been
neighbors together if you talk to Iraqis
they were just like this was Street by
Street this was sect by sect it's it's
nothing we want to see here and 20
years and it's ongoing people need to
understand when we look to the American
Civil War our view of civil war is
completely incorrect because that was
different if we actually had some kind
of legitimate Civil War we're talking
decades yeah absolutely your your
children will be born in this and they
will grow up in it and then one day
fight in it you think that there are
people that are that are at each other's
throats now wait until the killing
starts I know wait until the blood Feud
starts wait till it goes Hatfield mcoy
and then you add more and more and more
to the mix and it just so it could be
something as simple as this how does a
Civil War start the political tensions
are there we are standing on a powder
keg well we've already had with the Chaz
chop people were killed we already had a
trump reporter Aaron Danielson in um
what was it Portland OR Portland shot
and killed in the street for no
reason now there've been it was uh it
was doj doj went after that guy Michael
Ryle and he is no longer alive and it
seems to end it I wonder if the reason
why they went so heavy-handed after this
guy was they knew that if he was let go
you could start a blood Feud which would
result in like gang-like retribution and
and revenge killings but let's say that
we're at the point of heightened
political tensions in 2024 with Trump
already being Mo removed from Colorado
and you get uh someone shoots someone
else leftist shoots and kills
conservative can his brother says these
guys in in Colorado they're in Oklahoma
I like Colorado Oklahoma is example like
use and they say they killed my brother
and they fled and the police and the
government won't do anything about it so
they get a posi they go into Colorado
they get revenge yeah now that guy's dad
says these these Psychopaths from
Oklahoma stormed into my my home and
killed my son so he gets a posi but now
he's not after one guy he's after seven
yeah then you get seven people killed
then the brothers fathers and Friends of
those men say this fight's getting crazy
we need help yeah they call in look
maybe starts with neighborhood watch
militias then all of a sudden you've got
people lining up on the border holding
guns and then the Colorado people come
over and say John Smith now turn him
over and his men and they say never
going to happen they raise arms who know
I'm I'm not saying it's
but these are possibilities seems like
at point unun it's always something
small like that you never know what it's
it's all when you set the tensions this
high it's all unintended consequences in
the past decade there has all there's
been one standoff with the you know with
the people and the FEDS the Bund the
Bundy Ranch and the FEDS backed down
because they didn't want to get into a
gunfight with the PE with the with you
know dudes with rifles because that just
looks bad it's just bad all what they've
been there before yeah you know it's
just bad all around but that's happened
already once right the feds have not
forgotten about that and they don't like
it's not like they they just blow that
off they're not going to let that happen
again right you know the the the
apparatus that was designed to find
terrorists that was honed to be able to
find the dude hiding in the mountains
you know in in the middle of nowhere and
we've proven that it's basically you
know there's not really anywhere you can
hide from from the federal government
you know like that that apparatus is
turned onto the American population
currently it's been like that for a
minute with operation Northwoods they're
bloodthirsty I think a very important
distinction as well is one of the
mistakes this film makes with this map
state borders are meaningless yeah 100%
meaningless so in Colorado you've got a
a Northern District trying to secede and
join uh who who's who's north of them
which St is it is it Wyoming Wyoming
yeah they're trying I think I think
that's what they're trying to do you've
got California trying to suceed and join
the state cre create the state of
Jefferson or greater Idaho so Northern
Cal Republic of California would not
look like this the Republic of
California would look like a thin sliver
along the coast a lot of people assume
Cal you know look the conservatives and
the farmers are are the Eastern parts of
of California Liberals are in the
Western and Southwestern areas you go
north it gets more conservative that
country would rip itself in into into
pieces yeah so you look at all these
States as well the loyal States probably
would retain their form in the bulk in
the New England area because they're not
a conflict with each other but if you go
over here where you've got three
factions all surrounding you know
including Nevada yet Nevada would not
exist California would instantly Annex
territories trying to seize control of
water reservoirs and things like that
and the Western forces would take the
northern part and fortify it to bolster
the defenses of their own territories
Nevada would be ripped into a million
pieces in based on this map
but I guess people might still
instinctively or reflexively call it
Nevada the border is more of a
geographic marker than Declaration of
jurisic the state has deployed a
National Guard to like actually
reinforce a border this is a wild map
just because of of Utah like how would
that function I mean that's that's a
mass like see this is the problem these
borders are are impossible a that
enforcing that border is is is
impossible this state would be you got
to put dotted lines through it where
it's a split State maybe the movie is a
pro wall film yeah there's a big they
build a big wallall Nevada is just one
big perfect 30 foot wall all around the
entire Labyrinth by the end of the movie
walls yeah and Trump's face over it
turns out to be a prequel to Maze Runner
and it's like we had no idea we had no
idea well let's let's talk about the
next story that brings us to the actual
potentiality of Civil War and it's uh
it's this one the New York Post 12,000 m
rants cross Southern Border in a single
day Tuesday highest total
ever dude these videos are insane I
don't know if you guys have seen them
yeah uh and the federal government is
doing it intentionally 100% yep yeah so
why why would there be a Florida
Alliance in this film because the
southern states say you have you you
have you have inflicted this upon us
yeah yeah I mean it's it's funny when
they they call it like the Border crisis
like a hurricane is a crisis like you
didn't see that coming but this is 100%
the plan of the Democrats and every
single Democrat this isn't just Biden at
the federal level every single Democrat
in the house and the Senate they are
part and parcel of this they have voted
for it they voted against border
security right now they're going to the
mat and they're fighting against the
Republican plan to actually secure our
border and it's I mean we think right
now there's 10 million illegals that
have come into the country 118 15 to 16
maybe yeah and you know what Chicago's
mayor is saying no we can't it's the
Republicans that are doing it he said
it's the it's it's this governor of
Texas sending them all here it's his
fault meanwhile Texas is trying to stop
them with everything it has they Texas
just passed a law saying that it's
illegal to enter the state of Texas uh
illegally yeah illegally well because
typically border crossings are a federal
issue and the argument is Texas has no
right to deport only the Federal
Government Can Deport to other countries
Texas is basically asserting the right
to arrest and detain anyone and I think
what's going to end up happening is
these people who are coming in and mass
in an invasion and it is an invasion
they're going to be placed in very
serious uh squalor and horrify
theocrats will weaponize that and say
Trump isit so this is what they're
building up to when Trump gets eled I
would not be surprised if Trump says
it's time to deport these people and you
end up with camps full of migrants right
the Democrats then say oh no we warned
you he's Hitler yeah exactly well and
the Democrats I mean their their plan's
very diabolical they want a mass wave of
illegal immigrants they can pump into
all these different Urban centers so the
next time there's a census they can
count heads and from that they can make
new legislative seats I mean it's a pure
power play and then ballot Harvest their
way there they're eroding any kind of
verification for citizenship to be able
to vote in elections like in my state in
Washington and they don't care about any
of the Carnage that comes along with
that I mean 118,000 Americans have been
killed by fentel in the last couple
years that's come across the southern
border and like the Democrats don't even
talk about that I mean that's the number
one killer in our in our district right
now which is absolutely insane W I truly
believe that the the fact that the media
is so uh is so lock step with the
Democrat the DNC message that I don't
know that the American people can beat
that kind of
propagandizes to get answers down at the
border wall like by from the border
patrol or anybody like the sheriff's the
only one who can talk about it publicly
I don't think your average person
believes it oh yeah they can't because
the media doesn't report on like the way
they should because it's like watching
actual like like the skin of a human
erode right and you're watching like the
skeleton start to show itself I mean
it's a total mess all the f coming
through like millions of pounds down
there and it's just nonsense and then uh
no one's allowed to talk about I went to
the police station in Yuma cuz I was
getting the runaround from the border
patrol cuz they're allowed to talk to
you they pulled me over a bunch for just
being there really yeah and then the
police I'm like I'm wondering what they
think about this and they're not allowed
to talk to you they were going to make
me sign a form to at least do a a ride
along to see the the town with them my
wife had to sign that form but she had
to be there I was in Yuma my wife is in
West Virginia like they make it
impossible for journalist to do it right
the border of will give you a press tour
of all this stuff but that's like you
know what what you expect from a press P
you know that's what AOC got when she
cried yeah meanwhile we have videos of
actual federal agents removing border
barriers and allowing migrants to
illegally enter the country it's
absolutely insane it's the and when when
you look at who's coming into the
country I've been I went down to Yuma in
2021 too and I was down there in the
summertime pretty hot you know pretty
pretty treacherous Journey 116 degrees
in July treacherous Journey if you were
a refugee seeking Refuge but I didn't
see any of those people I saw guys that
were my age and younger that did not
look like they had just trekked across
the desert they were getting bust right
up there the whole thing I mean you
think like chaotic border scene there's
people like jumping across the border
saw a little bit of that but by and
large it was a very controlled flow of
people coming into the country and and
people don't think about like so Yuma is
a good example of how weird it is
because it's not like that giant Trek
people I think a lot of people imagine
going through the desert there's a
highway you can see through the wall
that you're getting dropped off at a lot
of people spend a lot of money to get
flown into the mexic airport then they
get driven to that Highway there's
people set up in tents on the highway
send you camouflage gear water
cigarettes you walk like 30 minutes to
the wall and then border patrols there
like TSA it's like soft TSA they got
water for you they got a tent they tag
your bags literally they got they had an
easier time talking to border patrol
than I did yeah when I was down there we
couldn't get Hotel I actually went down
there with representative Paul goar and
his team and we couldn't get hotels in
Yuma because the federal government had
booked the vast majority of them for
illegal IMM yeah it seemed like such a
controlled portal because the the
immigrants don't stay there either they
like they're there they get they gete
tickets bus tickets and yes send right
out yeah you go I mean there was people
tweeting coming I think coming home from
the TP USA event you guys yeah yeah she
was putting that stuff up but every time
I've flown into Arizona in the last
couple years like it's only been once or
twice but I've seen that exact same
thing every it's right up in your face
they're not hiding it she was going hard
after Delta and I'm like oh that sucks
because I really like Delta no I I
predict that Ashley stclair is bringing
down Delta and I I meant that is a
double anandra I'm sorry for people who
got mad at that but uh it I was like is
Delta trending because of her but the
videos were going around and it's good
people should know about it I mean when
I was I was a teacher in Westchester in
New York and they were flying illegal
immigrants into that airport yeah and
that's a small little area like you know
outside of the city do you guys remember
when uh the Biden admin was caught
trafficking children yeah this is this
is not even in dispute this is a fact
Joe Biden was engaged in human
trafficking I think that was actually
airport I'm talking about the
Westchester Airport that's right yep
it's insane and uh I think was it James
O'Keefe who who had the story someone
had a story where they no maybe it
wasn't James o'keef where they had
undercover video of one of the uh I I
think it was a border patrol guy being
like if the American people knew what we
were doing they would Revolt yeah Carrie
Lake shared a letter that she got with
me from a guy from border patrol and it
was like they've given up on the border
here the post he was at he's like
there's hours a day where it's not even
patrolled I don't think they've given up
I think plan well yeah yeah he to him he
thinks they given up right but this is a
controlled collapse is what it seems
like yeah maybe because they they fully
expect this country to be in in
fullscale conflict and who do you think
is going to fight against the American
people the people who want to be
receiving the benefits and privileges of
a country for which they are not
citizens I mean we got Senators that are
saying that we should put illegal
immigrants into the United States
military I think Los Angeles is trying
to make police officers right now
illegal immigrant I mean just absolute
Insanity yeah it's depraved doesn't make
any sense but it does for them this is
like their log it's logical for what
they do all they care about is power
that's it like they I mean what they're
doing in Colorado what they're doing at
the border with the fent and all the
only thing they care about is raw
political power yes if you operate under
the assumption that they actually have a
plan to help America none of this makes
sense right if you understand that their
plan is to destroy this country yep it
all makes sense 100% And then you roll
out Biden and you can write off
everything to him just being old and
incompetent like oh yeah it's just Biden
he just kind of stumbles around like
there's they just must be kind of messed
up like now this is a very well Machine
it's deliver plan the argument that they
make is that it's it's replacement
population because Americans aren't
having enough kids and it's because we
need the the people working to be able
to uh keep the Ponzi scheme of Social
Security going that's the argument they
make right right yeah okay okay yeah I
mean but that the war
trending well I mean realistically this
is
legitimately you know whatever people
think about how often we talk about you
know Civil War here uh this is you know
it's history making it's it's
unprecedented um and they're so um
what's his name um yeah they're locking
up journalists we had Owen just got out
yeah the guy from the blazes about to
get go in well that was today actually
yeah let me take a look at his uh down
at at the America Fest for his name I
forgot his name but that actor who was
arrested at the airport after the lady
Ballers uh Premiere like the feds he was
I guess at Jan 6 and the FEDS had
already dealt with him years like three
years ago and they went and they
arrested him at the airport after going
to the Daily wire Premiere I mean all of
this gives the regime a great excuse to
have another Biden red sermon where he's
like look you know these guy we can't
trust them you know what they did on
January 6 like they're already they're
already moving that direction but don't
worry my Administration has it under
control it's it's insane because when he
was running for president if are used
running Loosely like K staff was
donating money to get arsonist bail
money like they were severely
encouraging violence there was that
mayor out in maybe Portland who went to
the capital or the courthouse burning I
forget his name I always forget his name
but there's that crazy yeah that crazy
video of him like bathing in the smoke
like he was getting baptized he was
trying to pretend like he was going down
there and like he he attempted to be
cool with antifa they attacked him then
they tried to burn his condo down it's
like they're not going to be your
friends Ted you're not cool you might as
well just crack down him still to this
day he's he's attempting to appease
those people mostly because he's a
coward yeah clearly yeah yeah they did
like a lock in in his ba or in his like
Lobby or something yeah he lived in one
of those highrises downtown and they
basically like tried to light the whole
thing on firez so Steve Baker does not
have to surrender apparently it's been
reported that he won't have to surrender
until after Christmas okay but still
surrendering yeah sheesh his self
surrender would be postponed until after
Christmas and the justice department has
assigned a new a USA oh to his case you
know
Tucker made a really great point the
other night when he
said what someone's going to say no and
that that's another component of Civil
War yeah
mhm yeah how long was it like 10 no no
no it how was it 10 years ago or longer
remember that family in New Hampshire
didn't want to pay taxes and so they
just like locked their doors and then
the feds showed up and surrounded the
building and it was like this really
crazy thing I don't know it was a wild
story that happened I think at the end
of the 20 or something like that well
nobody really cares it's one family
refusing to pay taxes but this stuff is
every day what happens when you get one
by one by one people just saying no yeah
I mean there was that one guy remember
that one guy who they shot and killed he
was the morbidly obese elderly men yeah
who was posting yeah stupid crap years
old or whatever guy could be and so they
did a whatever a pre-dawn raid kicked in
his door like you need to send the entry
team to the 75 they already talked to
the guy too like they knocked door and
talk give me a break so Frank lunce
posted this just recently Colorado has
proven Trump's theory true that he is
the victim of political persecution his
poll numbers won't drop on the contrary
they will rise that kind of is worth
noting Frank Lun is not a pro Trump kind
of dude at all and if he can even see
that this is proving Trump right like so
there there was an argument to be made
that you know obviously I was I was
convinced that that they were after
Trump you know after January after
January 6th as soon as the the
impeachment stuff was going on I was
convinced they were after Trump but that
being said like someone like Frank Lun
to openly acknowledge it um I mean that
that that that says something about you
know what people are are going to see
when they look at the situation you hear
the Democrats talk about democracy
constantly and it is clear
that they are not interested in
democracy and this really I don't see
how you can make the argument that they
that they are and with a straight face
you know tyrants I want to pull up uh
some of these posts from Ashley stclair
as well as Taylor Hansen these depict uh
we have this from Ash Ashley stclair
migrants plac next to me on a premium
cabin still has a bag from a processing
center a majority of this flight is
migrants bust in from the processing
center can Delta please let all of their
customers know what medical screenings
are being done for these migrants
illegally crossing our border from all
over the world and being flown on their
flights the big move right now is to get
people to cancel and boycott Delta and
to give Delta the Bud Light treatment
because Delta is apparently receiving
funding from somewhere M to cover the
costs and facilitate human trafficking
Delta Airlines appears to be based on
what we're seeing from Taylor Hansen and
Ash stclair Delta Airlines appears to be
human trafficking and now the question
is who's paying for it yeah people
use Delta I think we are the taxpayers
perh the tax the boycotts a great idea I
think it's fantastic we've shown before
that we can make this we can actually
get a reaction from these companies and
corporations so that's probably the
right way to go Taylor Hansen on Twitter
says on X illegal migrants are littered
throughout the Phoenix airport right now
they're receiving priority boarding and
expedited security many have no idea
where they're going locations include
Charlotte Philadelphia New York City and
Texas multiple had to be escorted from
the women's resturant by security take a
look at this video you got like eight
right in this area yeah
yeah you guys speak Spanish he's asking
him where they're from saying he's
reporting on the issue and
obviously I think he said Mexico my
Spanish is very rudimentary but uh
there's a really funny moment where
someone from NBC said when you're just
trying to board a plane but someone
accuses you of being a migrant because
you you don't look like them or
something like this Ashley St Clair
points out they're holding processing
packets but NBC these people are evil
this is what they do yeah well they want
to scare everybody who's going to even
question ask the basic question of like
why are we let these people into our
country they're going to throw out
though you're racist to get them okay no
I'm sorry I'm not racist like please
don't accuse me of being racist again
like but no our country's being invaded
it's right up in your face you're paying
for it yes people need past that being
afraid of being name calleded yeah yeah
I feel like anyone that's in in politics
that's not a progressive leftist like
and that's you know that's not really a
a you know that's not a lot of people
the progressive left is they're loud on
the internet but there's not a whole lot
of them but at this point if you're not
a progressive leftist being called
racist should be you know irrelevant to
you because anytime that you do anything
at all that they don't like it doesn't
matter if they can somehow tacitly
accuse you of racism that's what they're
going to do so there's not a whole lot
of point in paying the attention that's
that's our wholeo you kill the language
yeah Hitler makes nothing means that
Hitler Insurrection misogyny he none of
those words mean anything anymore cuz
they just over use it I mean I was I've
been even complaining about the when it
comes to people using the term uh um
genocide when it comes to the stuff
going on in Gaza because it's not a
genocide if if if Israel wanted to
genocide the Palestinians in Gaza they
could literally genocide every single
living human being in Gaza so the idea
that it's a genocide is not I want to go
back to using words the way they should
be used yeah I get back to we just we
just have to ignore these people yeah
and for for too long people you know I
talked about this last night at tpusa I
said that uh for a while I believed that
there was no good and evil I believed
that it was just different worldviews
and that it was subjective and everyone
was trying to do what they thought was
right and you get older and you start to
learn no no there there there's
malicious evil their intention is harm
destruction making your life worse
helping no one that's evil mhm the the
your your average nihilist that's that
you know doesn't actually that really
believes there is no point to life and
stuff they don't have there's no reason
for them to do anything other than
whatever impulse you know catches their
fancy so you know if you don't believe
in I'm I'm of the opinion that if you
don't believe in some form of higher
power you likely are are going to just
be anilist that thinks that there is no
morality there's no real right or wrong
because everyone's going to die and you
know the heat death of the universe and
and and all that um um and if that's
your outlook on life there's not I mean
what's the real reason what there
there's no reason to say that anything
is better than anything else so why not
the you know why not watch it all burn
right NM increases like the short-term
benefits like that's what will make you
like the most animalistic violent
depraved you know they don't because
they don't care about consequences right
and they have no moral Center whatsoever
so you see all the stuff in the cities
where I remember when I lived in uh in
Brooklyn we would see kids there was a
game they were playing where they were
just pushing old people into buses right
like they'd be waiting at the sidewalk
and just be like it was just a game you
know where in the city in Manhattan
there was like kids just pushing old
people it wasn't just old people but you
had you had that whole wave of uh The
Knockout game yeah yeah yeah just try
and kill somebody yep full force just
attempted murder and and the city lets
them get away with it yeah there's no
meaning they have no meaning for life or
or care for it it's it's truly sad yeah
if you erode all the morals of the
society and then you take away the
actual laws that's exactly what happens
that's why you have to have some sort of
a moral code with the people in the
society but then you also have to have a
laws to to back those up you take away
you take away you you get Anarchy you
get what we have right now I one of the
reasons why I I didn't want to live in
New York anymore I was uh uh on the
other side of the Manhattan Bridge I
live down Broadway a straight shot I was
hanging out at a company party leave at
like 1:00
a.m. hell hell cab I think they I think
they make you use the app cuz like they
don't they don't want Uber so You' use
like an app to call a green tab or
something and I tell the guy I just live
straight down Broadway and here's here's
the number and he's like you got it and
I half sleep and then all of a sudden I
feel the car turning and I I'm like hey
what are you doing cuz you cross manhatt
Bridge you go straight down Broadway and
he's like oh I'm I'm sorry I'm I'm going
he starts weaving going left and right
he's trying to run run up the meter
thinking I was drunk or not paying
attention I don't drink and so I said
stop the car I'm getting out he said no
we were he was slowing down pulling up
to light the bill that the so far was
like the meter was like 495 I said stop
the car I'm getting out what are you
doing he says no and then as I feel the
car start to move I pop the door and
jump out and he slams the brakes and
comes out screaming demanding I pay him
I called the police immediately and I'm
like I I I walk into a gas station he
comes out screaming threatening me I
called the police says hey this C driver
was taking me for a ride he screaming at
me by the time the cop by the times time
the cops show up the meter's at 50 bucks
and the cops told me if I didn't pay
them the 50 bucks they to me Y what
ended up happening the cops took my
wallet pulled on my cash out handed it
to the cab driver and then told me to f
off they helped rob you that's right I
got robbed by the cops lady cops they
because the the cabs are a part of the
city's racket yeah they they pay they
pay the city they don't care that so
that guy was trying to rob me and and
the cops show up with guns and said do
it or
else insane yeah I'm I'm glad I'm not in
the city anymore we I mean we we left
when my wife was pregnant with our first
and it was just getting so depraved and
I she was working in the city and I was
working in the city or in just outside
of the city so sometimes you have to
take the subway without me which was
terrifying right and sometimes you take
a taxi but sometimes you take the subway
and there was like guys like screaming
about chopping your head off you know
and uh and then no one and then no one
doing anything like no one cared they
just tune out like whatever like yep
we're getting out of this place it's
totally insane it reminding me of the
70s in the city that's what I would hear
from my family who were cops or
firefighters in New York and it it's not
just you know it's not unique to New
York but that's how it was for sure in
the 70s you know that was like the
summer of burkowitz but like also fires
all the time and complete destruction so
that was the crazy part for me that the
Riots of 2020 when Portland like lit up
you had a lot of people that were on the
periphery of that were like well you
know this isn't really a bad thing they
were defending it I'm like no no guys
this this is horrible like they're yeah
but racism's also really bad like no
one's talking about race if if you
believe this has anything to do with
race I don't know what to tell you
they're destroying the entire City and
they're not going to stop and like they
literally haven't in Portland but you do
get this I don't know if some of it's
just people being complacent them hoping
that things are going to change but not
wanting to take action but you also do
get this fear I think of a lot of people
that they don't want to be called like
if you say that hey we're doing this for
racial Justice if you're we opening the
borders for racial Justice like then all
of a sudden like if you push back on
that they're going to call you a racist
and that's that's really powerful I
think for a lot of people makes a lot of
people live in fear I think all that CRT
stuff is all like tendrils of Marxism
cuz doing Marxist stuff power it's power
plays to take your power but they're
going to make you afraid of talking out
against it and like and you just gave me
another PTSD flashback of lockdowns when
I don't know how it was by you but in
New York they just like let loose
everyone in the prisons for lockdowns
they're just like yeah just it was like
Arkham you know they like I just go home
and then crime went crazy you know there
was some obviously some recidivism but I
don't know how it was like we're still
having major issues in Washington state
with them opening up the prisons AG
Ferguson who's now running to be our
next governor unfortunately he's had a a
program where he's letting violent sex
offenders out and then putting them into
communities into privately contracted
houses where these people are not
guarded whatsoever they're saying
they're doing it to you know reduce the
the population in the prison but they're
not choosing nonviolent offenders the
most of most people they're releasing
are violent sex offenders the only
reason some of it's gotten stopped is
because individual citizens in small
towns have said hey why is a private
company buying up a five-bedroom house
you know in rural thirston County and
state but that's the Democrats I say
they're the party of open borders and
open prisons anarcho tyny and I I agree
in prison reform but not like that right
exactly nonviolent prisoners sure but
you lock up the violent sex offenders
common sense I wonder why what a segue I
wonder why it is that they they
announced today this ruling to remove
Trump uh uh from the ball in Colorado
could it be that CNN reports dozens of
documents naming jeffre Epstein's
victims and Associates to be made public
in 2024 I chose CNN because uh you know
they they they they try to lie about the
sources we use here but here's the story
about 177 names will be released this
includes Associates recruiters staff
members uh this includes housekeepers
and it includes victims they're saying
uh according to this judge they have uh
two weeks 14 days to release these names
judge Loretta a presca the latest filing
in a case File to settle a case by
Virginia Roberts jefra she claimed
Epstein Abed her and uh uh Maxwell
defamed her I believe it was settled but
journalists have filed saying that these
people are are are publicly known public
figures and therefore the all the Doe's
they call it in the list should be named
there's still two weeks for people who
are on the list to come forward or to go
to the court and say hey don't release
my name for this reason maybe one person
ruins the whole thing for everybody else
but who knows this is the question I
posed to X earlier and I to ask you guys
and everyone listening like do you even
believe the list when it comes
out I mean it's not going to include the
names you want to include they're
they're going to have a housekeeper
you're you're going to you're going to
it's going to you know it's going to
Janet Smith and you're going to be like
I don't know you I think it's it's a
better question do you believe that the
list is complete when it comes out yeah
true I think it depends on who's on it
and why because they have the normal
people on there to make it seem more
normal they
need they they want to throw someone
under the bus mhm and I'm sure there are
high level people who are involved with
Epstein who are like just give the
people something you know this is what
happens with big corporations when they
engage in serious malfant some low-level
VP will get yeah charged and they'll be
like ah we got them and I think that was
part of The Big Short none of these
people who are engaged in this in this
fraud get criminally charged but there's
like one guy that they end up charging
saying he's the one there you got your
sacrificial lamb have a nice
day yeah this is like something where I
think you need like multiple judges that
could all have access to this so they
all they all release at the same time so
it's not like just one judge and it
could be easily contaminated and there's
been there's just been so many lies told
around this entire thing this entire
Epstein Affair that like you're right
why would you believe theist he's been
given good treatment in jail decades ago
like his roots are so deep I just I have
a hard time trusting anything and they
somehow convicted uh how do you say your
name g Max convicted her of sex
trafficking but like they would they
would not say hoi sex traffic to right
yep all of it's so absurd this is uh
this is our last week before we take off
for Christmas it's going to be great so
what's uh what is it today's Tuesday so
uh what is Friday the 21 no Friday's
22nd 22nd 22nd yeah Saturday's 23rd it's
going to be an awesome Christmas and I'm
hoping that as I am sitting there
relaxing wearing a a fuzzy sweater of
some sort and drinking cocoa that the
Christmas present we end up getting
maybe not on Christmas but soon will be
some accountability as it pertains to
the Epstein list yeah you know my view
is is you will get coal Tim pool you
will get coal I have a feeling but I but
look I'll tell is here if some of the
names that come out it's like a
housekeeper I'm fine like I'll take I'll
take a housekeeper if you were cleaning
up for this man and you knew what he was
doing I want to know who you are yeah if
you saw and it's not all we want but
it's a start those like restraining
chairs he had in his bathrooms and stuff
and you're like living in that house
cleaning it up yeah for sure like who
installed those for sure for sure look
the if you get people that were on the
premises this is how investigations go
you you get someone that was there that
knows something you interrogate them or
you investigate them who do they what do
they know who who else do they know like
that's the way they the investigations
normally go whoever comes out and they
they actually name there should be now I
don't know if it actually will happen
but there should be pressure or some
some da or whatever that is trying to
find more information about it because
clearly
they have been slow rolling it and they
came out and said that the names on the
list you know back when it when they
when FC first died or whatever they they
came out and said that the names on the
list they it was too volatile to let
them out you know thank you sir she did
say died in quotes um and I agree I I'd
like that to be the case but I think of
things like when someone is running for
politics and they all of a sudden he's
on the or she's on the we website and
then people are like well the W puts
them on there to discredit them or
they're on the we website and that
discredits them you know so it's like a
constant back and forth of these scops
as well like who who's going to be on it
and maybe there's like a who's going to
benefit from that person being on it is
what I'm worried about you don't know I
just keep it in mind when it comes to
the the W stuff I I kind of just always
get the impression that only in the past
year two years have kind of has it
become broadly known throughout the the
I guess the dissident community that the
WF is actually really really bad it was
there was a time where like talking
about Davos and talking about the the
people that get together at Davos and
and the WF and and the Council on
Foreign Relations and stuff is if you
brought any of those things up in any
type of critical context then you were a
crazy person you know you were you was
that was Alex Jones stuff well well not
just him Bill Burr before he was
neutered used to talk about those
meetings all the time on Conan O'Brien
show yeah and so that and that's it's
like if you're critical of it you're a
crazy person but if you were listening
to SP brzinsky talking to M and Joe
about it on MSNBC at 8:30 in the morning
they're talking about what the WF is
doing or what the what the Council on
Foreign Relations all these these
organizations they're real and they
actually do things and stuff if you're
talking about them and and you are
praising them then obviously this is
just normal Nos and and organizations
and stuff but if you're critical well
then you're Alex Jones yeah for sure so
I mean obviously it's it's just it's the
Paradigm of like it's it's not happening
and you're crazy but if it is it's a
good thing that it's actually happen
exactly oh that's so true frustrating as
hell it's terrifying well I hope the
list comes out and we can have
accountability would be great cuz
accountability seems completely rare
these days it's just we're so hyper
politicized it's like it's hard for me
to even see accountability on the
horizon accountability I don't I don't
believe in accountability anymore it's
just the use of political persecution to
to sty your opponents you know again and
generally that's you know conservatives
you or or people that are outside of the
the norm of progressive sensibilities
but I mean again we we talked about it a
little bit you know you look at at
Santos and granted he clowned on all of
Congress and he clowned on basically his
entire District cuz they did elect him
you know so I mean he he did was it poo
that called him gay Joker this morning I
don't I don't know incredible go look at
Poo's twiter page don't disrespect
Santos no he I think he meant it in a
good way because it was a hilarious
interview Santos treated Congress the
way that Congress deserves to be treated
that's Absol and that's that's why I'm
I'm surprised you're such a supporter he
treated them exactly how they deserve MH
and the crazy thing is the guy got no
due process none I he got no due process
and you're right his district did elect
him and he's New York has their
primaries I think like in the early
spring summer so he was way less he was
like eight months out from getting
probably quite a few hard primary
challenges but then they came in and
said no this guy's guilty we got to
throw him out right now like why didn't
they just let the process actually work
I don't know why Republicans have to
rush in automatically say no no no we'll
take care of this like we'll kick this
bum out of here meanwhile Menendez has
got gold bars from the government of
Egypt and he's are the Democrats going
to kick him off the Foreign Affairs
committee like no way no way
unbelievable 2024 is going to be fun
it's going to be wild I don't know what
else to say I mean it's we're we're I've
been saying before I can't see you know
normally when something happens I have
like several ideas of what I think it
might lead to and you know a lot I get
wrong A lot of times sometimes I get it
right I mean with like Colorado kicking
Trump off off the ballot I think it's
like I'm in the ballpark you know what I
mean yeah when I I I I I had Media
Matters roasting me well I say roasting
they claimed that I likely had four
knowledge of January 6th because in
September of 2020 I said these
oathkeepers and proud boys and 3centers
they're going to storm to DC in November
and just like storm the White House or
something and then they were like he
must have known about January 6 I was
like first of all it happened in Jan not
November second of all they didn't go to
the White House they went to the capital
building and more importantly it's cuz I
read the
news it wasn't a real prediction if I
had any influence on the January sixths
I would have told him to go to all the
people that the houses of the people
that that live work at Media Matters no
I don't I take that back I think the
problem not on the door and have a
polite conversation in any legal context
but my point is it's starting to come in
view with the removal of trump in
Colorado it's starting to starting I'm
starting to you know get an idea of
things that could happen from this you
end up with Trump uh uh unable he not
that he'll be removed from every state
in the primary but just enough to that
he can't win yeah you end up with Ronda
Sanz as the nominee The Establishment
says guys look you know we we we're not
happy with this but we we we can't let
Joe Biden win so everybody go out there
and vote for Dan santis Trump's
supporter is gonna say screw off yeah
exactly I've heard you say a bunch like
it's hard and it's I agree it's hard to
Envision this future right cuz like if
you read all news you can you have a
sense of the pattern that happens and
I've been thinking you know like we
might have a normaly bias for all all of
these past years until covid then it
turned into absurdity and now it's like
you have to have an absurdity bias but
it's impossible to guess absurdity so
everything just constant G yeah it's the
new normaly is the absurdity so and it's
almost ties into uh elon's quote about
the most likely outcome is the most
entertaining one except it's for
politics it's the most like chaotic and
depraved one you know and it's hard to
to gauge at because it's just we're so
far gone and all the Democrats care
about is power I mean they've proven
that they will basically burn the entire
country down and so what's the next
level after that what's the next level
from 2020 World War I pretty I mean it's
incredibly frightening yeah will they
get us into World War II I mean Biden's
last addressed the nation he said we all
have to unify because you know we
potentially could be at War I mean and
and look at the geostrategic uh
situation right now between the Middle
East between what's happening Eastern
Europe like yeah and I worry about we've
gone through this age of character
assassination Trump you know obviously
the the biggest one at the top of that
what and and then when Phil talks about
Frank Lun recognizing this new thing
it's almost like they're all starting to
realize that the character assassination
economy is not working anymore and then
what goes back you know it's not like
they haven't dealt in blood before it
stopped working before Trump because the
reason you got Trump was because they
called Mitt Romney a Nazi when when you
have the most Boy Scout ass dude in
America he's a Saltine yeah he is he is
absolutely a Sal in a suit the he is the
most boring most boy scout scout ass guy
that is has probably run in the past 50
years I mean you could not get any more
white breed and and less offensive and
if you're calling him a Nazi there's
nowhere else to go so what happened was
the American people were just like it
doesn't matter who we elect and that's
why they were just like who cares that
he said grab him by the because
nothing is no one is good enough for the
Democrats the the politics of we respect
each other was tossed out you know a
decade earlier a decade before uh before
Trump ran you know so the idea
that that
respectability you know has been
something that the left has actually
cared about I don't know if they ever
did solinsky wrote the The Playbook on
it in the 60s or whatever and it could
be that I you know I didn't see it until
recently or whatever but it has been the
the politics it has been power politics
from the left for as long as I can
remember as long as you know definitely
all of my adult life you know I think
we're witnessing we're in it right now
is what Eisenhower warned about with the
military-- industrial complex but like
within that complex is the corporate
press they're an arm of that right and
that's where all the scops or the just
the blatant lying is coming from the
military-industrial complex no is no
longer just Boe Ron and and companies
like that and you know space
manufacturers it's also Google it's all
your technology companies because all of
that has become intelligence it's all
data collection and it's also the media
because because of the propaganda so the
military-industrial complex is no long
when when you hear people complain about
or criticize the military industrial
complex they're talking about Google
they're talking about Facebook they're
talking about paler they're talking
about all the tech companies in in
addition to Ron in addition to uh you
know
cuz they can be cuz those things can be
like in your brain and in your
day-to-day pattern while they're making
the things that are going to destroy you
in that pattern absolutely the the the
media produces the content and the tech
companies produce the vehicle that
introduces the the propaganda to the
American people and your average person
I I see it all the time with a lot of
people that I'm that I'm really good
friends with that are not involved in
politics that are only tertiary the only
time that they talk about politics or
whatever is When Donald says something
that the media drums up that they tells
them they should hate him for or
something on both sides yeah and now and
now people are starting to be like well
what's going on with Elon Musk what's
why is Elon Musk a bad guy and it's like
these people have no idea that they're
being entirely propaganda contr they
have no they have no reason to dislike
Elon Musk only what they've been told to
think by the media Rolling Stone made a
a list of nine unfunny Things El did you
know I saw the rape magazine decided
that they have criticism for musk unreal
unbelievable one I mean and one of the
bigger reasons they've gone after Trump
really since he took took the White
House was he's he is an a front to the
military-industrial complex because he
came in and said like I don't think we
need to be at War all the time and then
he made the cardinal sin of trying to
get us out of Wars but then also saying
like hey wait a sec why are we providing
security guarantees for all of Europe
like why are we providing the security
guarantees for CI exactly why aren't you
guys paying yeah but it's a good
business if they don't pay cuz then we
pay more the military industrial complex
gets further and further you know more
control and they get more rich like but
Trump was in the front to that and
that's what they're throwing the kitchen
sink at them I think people fail to
realize that it's like actually they're
going after Trump for being radically
moderate like they say he's a radical
but he's actually trying to get us out
of all these entanglements all he did
was ask him to pay their fair share
right what's wrong with that I me know
they sign the contract time yeah you
know the '90s Dem '90s New York Democrat
Donald Trump is a farri extremist right
exactly because yeah they move so far
left everyone's far right now uh I
whoever hasn't seen the Eisenhower
speech I please go watch it it's the
last speech he gave in the Oval Office
before he gave the presidency over to
JFK K and then I mean it is such a
beautiful speech uh and it's like it's
almost like poetry uh and he predicted
everything that we're in right now Y and
then there's I forget what the name of
the speeches that or interview that
Kennedy gave two years later but he
pretty much in that interview sums up
how horrible the presses and then I just
you marry those two things together and
here we are y i uh just uh I'm going to
Tweet the uh Eisenhower speech yeah it's
so good and then I think two three years
later was the Kennedy American
University address where he talks about
the end of pax America and how we don't
forces yeah exactly how we don't need to
be projecting power everywhere we can
actually have a piece in our time like
and then after that the National
Security State did what they did we been
ever since well at some point in there
the Joint Chiefs of Staff came to him
with an idea to start a war with Cuba
right called Northwoods yeah yeah yeah
and he turned that down he fired that
guy General ler decorated War uh hero
and then he went and took over NATO and
then at that point is when NATO did some
Maybe dirty dealings with the years of
lead in Italy which was their political
uh false flags on either side for 20
years yeah um so yeah it's it's insane
welcome then yeah In Our Lifetime we've
had the Iraq War lies and then now with
the same propaganda for Ukraine the same
propaganda for you know I mean Middle
East all this stuff you know I think my
advice everybody would just be is uh
we're so very close to Christmas less
than a week away to make sure that when
you see your family you give them a hug
and let them know that you love them cuz
2024 is going to get
crazy yeah yeah yeah I mean the world is
still I always say this too like the
world is so beautiful and I'm so like
grateful for God I'm grateful for the
Earth and how beautiful everything is
and my children and everything that
we're talking about that's so evil and
depraved it reminds me just how I I
cherish everything you know and it makes
me cherish it more honestly and it makes
you fight I mean there's a lot of folks
right now who I know and and and I live
in a beautiful rural community where
it's very possible to completely tune
out all this BS and just say like I'm
not going to even participate with this
I got my church I got my job I got my
family like we're we're going to be fine
and in general that's true because
people are self-sufficient they're
independent but man this could this
could get away from us so quickly and
becomes so dark that people got to stay
in the fight for 24 unun but you
especially if you have kids because you
don't know who they're going to meet and
these ideas are just percolating down
from Every Which Way and they're going
to find your your kids and you got to
raise them in the right way know how to
fight those ideas you need to know
because it's like you got to have an
immune system of your ideas and you need
to that immune system has to encounter
bad ideas so you know how to defend
those right exactly and if you don't
have that immune system those bad ideas
will just collapse and someday you're
going have to explain to your kids what
you did in the year of Our Lord 2024 I
mean you are you're going to have to say
like hey here's what I was doing like I
was you know I was actually in the fight
was the for myun you don't want to be
the who's like well in24 things seem
just like really nasty so we kind of
checked out that that's it's not really
a very good example nope we're going to
go to Super Chat so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and head over
to
timcast.net as you send to become a
member get access to that Discord server
and also head over to the best song
ever.com click download your price and
you can uh help us by purchasing the
song the new song we released together
again a cover of the song by Jeremy
boring and Michael nolles and uh we're
just building parallel economy over here
so we got some music maybe you like it
maybe you don't if you like it you can
buy it and if enough people buy it we'll
hit the Billboard charts we'll get
Jeremy and Michael nolles Smoky Mike and
the god king up on that Billboard charts
that' be that'd be absolutely amazing
and then maybe one day we'll sell
500,000 of these songs and uh we'll get
Michael NS at gold record and Jeremy Bor
gold record on their on their daily wire
wall and we'll have it we'll have it
behind us too if that ever happens I
mean you know Phil is he doesn't care
he's over not paying attention he's got
seven of them so oh I opened for
Metallica listen there is there is
nothing better than seeing your friend
succeed dude yes that picture of you you
post the other day that was is amazing
which one it's him maybe it was the
Metallica show no it was from Rock USA a
couple years back it was it was EP
it's him and like just a sea of people
in front of him it was one of the last
shows we played with Oli before he
passed away I think and it was the last
tour that we did wow and uh it we didn't
I didn't think we were going to be
playing at all like we there were
thunderstorms all day long and we flew
in our flight we thought we were going
to be delayed and everything and it was
they shut down stage over and over but
they kept saying no we're going to get
you on no we're going to get you on and
I'm like this is not happening and then
like 20 minutes before we're supposed to
play they start rolling our stuff on
stage I'm like this is actually
happening and we play and it's
ridiculous it's we only played for maybe
30 minutes but like there's literally
thunder and lightning going on I got I
have some videos that I are on my
Instagram page of it from that night but
it was it was amazing there's like like
50,000 people or something like that and
we we headlined the show the whole show
after we played the show ended because
of all the thunder and lighting and
stuff it was Go All That Remains after
this episode everybody cheers
than all right let's grab the super
chats we got Clint Torres says howy
people Tim Bravo for being trooper and
creating content for us today yeah
working off of uh you know 2 hours and
10 minutes of sleep all day that was a
bit of a nap on the plane yeah but I
think I only got like 40 40 minutes yeah
yeah it's wobbly little wobbly there's
no you can't Recine in these is a
private jet the they're not it's not
luxury I mean it is in the sense that
you get to fly when you want to fly and
it's a private jet I get it I get it but
there's no reclining you you're sitting
upright on a bumpy shaky ride the whole
time and the conveniences is you can fly
at your convenience and cheese cheese
platters well that was just something we
brought on the plane you know what I
mean you can bring your own cheese
platter exactly it's like you fly first
class you can recline plug your your
laptop in put you know stret your feet
out go to sleep and if you get real
first class on those on those bigger
flights they got beds but no no no TSA
though right with the private jet you
just go right okay that's that's a
pretty big deal the the main benefit of
flying private is once we finish the
show the plane's waiting for us oh man
we're not waiting for the plane yeah and
then we get home at 521 in the morning
but you know I I wouldn't want to go
through TSA and stuff like that however
a full a full laid down bed I could have
got some sleep true but it is what it is
you know you don't look a gift horse in
the mouth it was made possible thanks to
our friends at tpusa that was really
amazing and we're grateful to have been
a part of it and the whole thing went
off without a hitch like from from
watching it from you know the stream and
stuff it looked great it was awesome
yeah shout out to Serge and Kell Carter
quality was amazing
amazing all right I'm not your buddy guy
says before before we watch the stream
folks switch your drinks to water if you
haven't already because you're going to
get alcohol poisoning tonight with the
famous line what what what did I say
like 23 times someone's keeping track it
was like 15 before like we got into the
segments
yeah let's grab some super chats where
are we
at make it simple says major win for
Colorado no more Trump 2024 well there
you go
buddy good for you David violet Haley
sorry David Violet says they want a
reckless reaction from the non-left
don't feed the trolls instead change the
culture and meme them to defeat I agree
they they want you to overreact do not
give it to them yeah don't take the bait
it's it's quite simple actually Donald
Trump is right now asking for you at at
his at his rally and iway said just show
up and vote overwhelm it vote vote vote
100% it's any you know this is the funny
thing anybody who's who's saying like
look if you believe Trump is our best
chance right now and uh uh uh you like
what Trump has to say and what he's
doing any I see these people being like
no Trump is wrong we have to go and do
insert X Y andz activism or whatever and
I'm like it's by fed or a leftist to
dude I totally agree yeah it's like
totally agree dude we we want to we want
to we want to make money we want to take
care of ourselves our families we want
to be responsible we want to stay in
shape and uh we want to pay attention to
what's going on we want to be active
politically and now it's really simple
we've got not just Donald Trump but
we've got you know Joe you're running
we've got people running at uh the the
federal level the state level local
level Carrie of course and and that's
the mission right now yeah they they're
trying to you know what they're doing
you know I I was hanging out with Tucker
after the show and I said you know I was
on your show before he's like of course
right you know and I was like yeah and
Boston with the antifa thing years ago
this antifa guy was throwing punches at
me but stopping right before my face
because what he wanted was for me to
throw the hit exactly I didn't do it I
just stood there and I was like are you
doing something right and so Tucker is
like oh come on my show and I'm like
that's what they're doing now that's
exactly right so we're we'll just mind
our own business yes everyone please
remember the governor Whitmer kidnapping
plot like that's what they want and that
was mostly fed like right it's some like
but look they they'll find some fumbling
bumbling dude who doesn't know what's
going on and they'll be like can you
hold this uh gun real quick you'll be
like sure thing buddy and they'll be
like help help he's got a gun and you're
like wait what can you put on this Red
Hat real quick for us they'll make him
the example for everybody yeah ex
everybody well there was that story
recently where the guy was in the mall
or whatever and then he took his own
life and said I don't want to do this I
don't do this and they found a bunch of
weapons and stuff yes wasn't that at at
uh in Colorado wasn't that the uh the
amusement park is that what it was I
think it was amus Park he he was going
to kill a bunch of people in that was
after well he wrote something like I
just wanted to come inside I I I don't
want to do this and then he kills
himself and like people were like MK
Ultra like what the was that yep that's
part of that milit milit industrial
complex all right Jimmy Grenier says Tim
the decision of the Court was stayed
they only granted a pending decision to
create a headline provoke his supporters
so they have a basis to uh definitively
remove him from the ballot it was stayed
and that is the trick so that I think
it's the other way around so that people
on the left can be like oh it was stayed
calm down perhaps the headline the
staying of it was completely irrelevant
has nothing to do with the ruling we're
we're talking the this the stay of the r
expires on the 4th of of J of January
yeah that that's when they will finalize
their ballots I don't know that the
Supreme the federal Supreme Court can
overrule a private organization
operating under state law we'll
see wful Sensei says I am once again
asking that we start today's episode by
just saying Civil
War you missed it I didn't get it it's
not how it went down unfortunately Noah
Sanders says we need good people to step
up and primary these awful people
timcast members rise up and run against
your local failed or failing politicians
do it not just timcast members everyone
everybody you know yeah and that's the
big thing because when we're on the
stage with Tucker Luke says everyone go
around and say who you think VP should
be and he's laughing because we know
what he's doing because everyone's going
to say tucker yeah Tucker should be the
vice presidential pick and it wasn't
until the idea was floated that everyone
was like yes okay because before that
it's like I guess VI well Tucker might
be the VP Trump mentioned it he was
asked and he said that'd be a good idea
and we're all instantly like yes yeah I
don't think Tucker wants to do it though
I can't imagine after just starting the
company and all that stuff you I thought
it was going to be Carri till she
announced to run for Senate uh yeah the
sounds like it could be but I don't
think it's going to be him either
honestly yeah he I mean Tucker's
probably more valuable on the outside
Trump gonna Cho himself for VP yeah you
a double Trump ticket yeah I mean to
that that point from that Super Chat
they're right though people do need to
step up and like if you're not happy if
you're represented a primary my primary
at a 12- year incumbent and beat her
last cycle I mean it's hard but you know
I didn't have any experience in politics
I just went around and started talking
to people and we you can do it at the
Grassroots level it's not easy but it's
doable yep all right where are we at Aon
says let's take all Democrats Democrats
off ballots in conservative and swing
States I'm ready yes but
understand right now they're doing the
primary they want to make sure Trump
can't win the primary then Ronda santis
will win that's why they won't stop Ron
will win as a
dishonorable of no integrity and then
they'll say oh but but this is you know
oh gez I mean he's the nominee what are
we supposed to do we're just playing by
the rules so if you remove Joe Biden and
other Democrats yes I agree but
understand Biden there's no primary for
Biden the Democrats are too smart for
that like they they won't do a premier
they've all already rallied around Biden
they forced out RFK there's some other
guy but they're not giving them any air
time so yeah the Democrats are very
organized MH the be says does the
establishment just think that all these
Trump voters will go go back to voting
for people like Ron D sanct demonius or
Nikki Haley as a smart man once said
where is the off-ramp he did indeed say
it but I don't think you understand
January 6 is the trial balloon for what
they plan to do for people like
you you want to be an undesirable maggot
or what what else do they call him what
what
deplorables maggots yeah
insurrectionists insurrectionists
election deniers sure MH I mean you know
I I feel like they they've got your your
history so they they know what what
videos you're watching so if you're
commenting on Tim p uh yeah streams and
stuff you're already they got you buddy
and think about it this way 15 to 16
million illegal immigrants brought in
illegally uh by Joe
Biden how do you Deport these people
let's say Donald Trump says we're not
playing games all these people have to
go home this was illegal in the first
place far- leftist stage a bunch of
violent assaults on detention
centers whose side do you think the
illegal immigrants are are going to
fight on yeah of course that's a 15 16
million group of people many of them
young males yeah and they're going to be
like hey look this side claiming to be
the legitimate government is saying we
are okay to be here
yeah many Bad actors are part of that 15
million how many sleeper cells from you
know Iran Hezbollah Hamas like whatever
you name it Isis like Chinese Communist
Party chines Communist party yeah yeah
they're not it's not just south
Americans coming over it's people from
all over the world
was they were saying it's not Mexicans
like it's like it's like Africans people
from China a ton of folks in the Middle
East when I was there yeah they had a
stack of Middle Eastern passports right
yep let's grab some more Super chats
skulky bonees says these days Colorado
is basically just California's largest
county
yep shred shred Kowski what argument is
there for voting Trump over vake if a
has better policy and is 100% not going
to have Haley as VP
what do what do you mean because we want
Trump to win I don't what is the
argument
that Trump will finish out his
presidential term he'll complete his Arc
he will uh take actions that you can't
take as a first-term president that's
probably it's it's simple the getting in
will want to do a lot of things and you
know in your first term at 70% second
term is 100% Trump's asking for a final
100% term you should get it absolutely
yeah prior record four years of peace
and prosperity I mean even all the
criticisms of him we had four great
years but then also I mean Trump's very
unique I think the fact that he's he's
the age that he is he's independently
wealthy they've already thrown the
kitchen sink at him he's got nothing
else to lose he's he's basically on one
more Mission I mean I think he's the
he's the perfect guy for the Times we're
liin yeah but but uh I'd vote for yeah
he's he's he's fantastic if for some
reason Trump is out and ain't going to
be I'm not voting for Dan santis or
Haley yeah and there 2028 too Des santis
feel like has got to be I don't know you
know I thought he was a really great
Governor we like his policies and the
things he's enacted but then you look at
his campaign and I really start to
wonder if the dude is just like a
mannequin like they they tell him what
to say and when to say it that's it yeah
as as governor of Florida he's just
there saying like I don't know tell me
what to do I have no idea because I
don't know how you could be so
incompetent when it comes to running a
presidential campaign but competent as a
governor he seemed to handle the media
better though as a governor like there
were sometimes he would he would School
the media that he's that person's gone
in his element as a governor yeah yeah
Patrick of Ohio says when is Michael
going to pay up to Roseanne we need some
followup ah it's not looking good for Mr
malice he's going to be here this week
you still got to wait until the end of
the end of the at least of course of
course you can't call the fight before
the fight happens come on you know but
uh but again this is uh the you the odds
are for Roseanne here for you know a
little bit maybe it's like leaning it's
like you know plus 100 for uh uh for
malice in the odds you know Roseanne's
the favorite going into 2024 but we'll
see we'll see what was the BET Roseanne
said there won't be an election oh okay
and the question is what does that
really mean does it mean nobody votes
and everyone's like oh gez or does it
mean No One Believes the the election is
is legitimate in any way and I think
Roseanne's probably right if you use a
very broad definition of no election MH
if in the sense that Trump's name's
being removed from the ballot you can
argue there was a procedural election
but you rem move the front runner from
the ballot there was not an election
right so we'll
see what do we have triple flip says
Phil help me propose to my girlfriend
when is your tour bring her on stage bro
she's super hot so am I so are you let's
go
viral so I'm not sure why your
girlfriend being super hot would matter
to
me just saying you know he's got a
proposition for you buddy well you know
maybe we we'll see it depends on where
where you live so so but we're going
we'll be on tour probably like in in May
so Jesse Faircloth says it seems like
the Democrats are getting closer to
their Confederate Roots When instead of
instead of further and I'm seriously
worried about the country that I
love yeah yeah it's a good
point that is correct what do we have
here Ryan phle says and this is how our
Democratic Republic dies with thunderous
Applause I think Rosanne might have won
her bet it's time to start saying no to
Democrats from here on out it's crazy
what what this is this is just
absolutely an insane day so it's a crazy
week you know I'm really worried about
the I'm worried that I'm going to go on
Christmas vacation and then something
real crazy going to happen and I'm going
to be like you know sitting on a slope
somewhere or something like oh you look
at that yeah so uh Alx tweeted this and
this is I guess Jesse wat was saying but
the Colorado lawsuit was filed by a
Soros funded Outlet decided by an all
Democrat appointed Supreme Court and the
Dem Democrat Colorado secretary of state
within a split second was celebrated on
MSNBC the idea that this is not a a
total op by you know political op is
ridiculous and the idea that that this
actually stands I I I can't wrap my head
around that you know that's why I say
Civil War as often as I do because the
only reason we're not in one right now
is because Republicans are following
Trump's lead and Trump is not an
insurrectionist and Trump is not a
dictator right because if Trump did come
out and say this is it the line's been
breached it's time then this country
would instantly go insane but I think
Trump is confident that we can win he
can win and I think culturally we are
winning yeah the cultural thing is the
most important thing because they do
stuff like this it's an over attack from
powerful special interest on our
elections and everything like that yeah
but look at look at last night when we
do this show with Tucker Carlson we've
got the biggest numbers on YouTube we've
got uh the new song we put out uh daily
wies got their movies coming out
culturally we are winning you've got
budlight failing you've got Target
failing now like we're we're claiming
cultural victories Trump's polls are
through the roof Biden is at is at this
worst his worst approval rating ever
they do this because they want that
reaction we don't got to give it to them
that's why I so smart with Trump was
saying it during that speech when he
saying I just need you to vote because
that's the one thing they fear that's
why they're doing all this they fear us
just coming out in a massive wave and
actually mobilizing people and voting I
completely agree does it mean there's
not there's not going to be applied
resistance certainly there's going to be
some crazy lawsuits and Tom foer when it
comes to 2024's election pay attention
but that's why Trump was saying
overwhelm it you know unquestionable
numbers yep absolutely I agree 100% now
they're like quick take his name off the
ballot ex when when they do that when
they go for a a win by disqualification
imagine you know we just watched the
Covington Edwards match imagine if one
of the fighters tried getting their
opponent disqualified on a technicality
instead of fighting them we'd be like
they think they're going to lose yeah
absolutely technicality he can't fight I
win I get the belt nah I I mean I
imagine the the bureaucracy and the the
powers that be in in the quote unquote
deep State they don't they understand
what it means if Trump does get back
into the position of the president you
get the Office of the President
president that he's going to have a far
deeper understanding of the processes
necessary to do what he said he was
going to do before yeah so you know
there's dudes that are like my my my
401k is on the line if Trump gets
elected my kids's not going to blah blah
blah school and I can't have that you
know extra house or whatever garbage
thing they're thinking you know Panzer
says bloody
Colorado oh boy
that's
right I'm not your buddy guy also says
this is bleeding Colorado the rhyming of
Kansas perhaps it it would be so soon
though I mean it is fair if you look at
the history there was concern in 18 in
the 1820s about Civil War and it took 40
years for something to finally happen
yeah it could be 40 years who knows I
think I think it's strong possibility
Trump wins and then it takes several
decades before anything actually
shatters Trump wins he starts enacting
reforms and and clean corruption and it
works for a while and then maybe that's
it it doesn't have to repeat itself if
we learn it from the from the past
yeah all right Missy kin says Tim do you
think they will steal the election and
use migrant militias to fight the Civil
War well uh who is they though we
talking about like Democratic political
establishments or like the woke faction
whatever it may be uh steal the election
what do you mean by Steel if they are
going this what what really bothers me
about the stole the steal the election
narrative is the idea that elections
were ever
Fair it's like you thought this one was
not fair do you think any of the other
ones were M none of them are they're
miniature Civil Wars where people are
just agreeing not to punch each other in
the face as they try to find out find a
way to legitimize their their grasping
of power from the you know taking the
Reigns and most people just say okay
okay you you have the power this time
but now everyone's saying no basically
you know Michael mice has a good threat
he's talking about on Twitter on X where
people are saying now that the courts
are politicized this country is doomed
or whatever and he's like courts are
always politicized always it's and and
and he's right so now what's happening
is there are just two politicized courts
that's it you have the traditional
American View and you have the
progressive neoc communist
View and they're going to be at odds
with each
other lithian cross says how bad would
it be if if the Epstein list is faked to
have anti-establishment individuals on
it names like Elon or Trump himself I
would be willing to bet that Trump will
be named in the documents I would not be
surprised at all right but that doesn't
mean anything the the names that we're
getting are not all clients or workers
or anything like this a lot of them will
be clients a lot of them will be
recruiters uh a lot of them are just
housekeepers or genitors some of them
are actually
victims
so yeah maybe maybe Trump himself will
be named in the document because the
document will say you know uh uh at at a
at a party held by Donald Trump and
right now it's listed as a do MH so yeah
of course RFK junr could be on it he's
admitted to being on the plane and
flying around yeah that's that one's an
interesting one huh MH yeah I wonder
about what's going on with Ark Jr yeah
that's a weird it's almost like he got
tipped off he was going to be on the
list but you know who knows yeah he was
with there with he was with him with his
kids looking for bones or something Mark
cample says plot twist the lazy left
sees Trump disqualified they don't vote
Trump wins electoral and popular vote
they reel in horror sparking Civil War
it's a fair point actually because Trump
being removed we have these Democrats
all cheering they may now believe Trump
can't win and many of them may just stop
caring oh what do you mean I thought
Trump got disqualified yeah well that
was one state it was I wasn't paying
attention that was the mistake they made
in 16 I mean they they all the media
said that Hillary was going to win a
landslide and oh yeah you I never forget
laughing so hard I was I was drinking
Margaritas watching the needles all in
favor for Hillary just all a sudden go
like this and I was just like I was just
laugh maniacally it was amazing it was
awesome Mr invisible says Tim I'm in
Colorado our last local election had
zero right in option and no other
choices than Democrat physically on the
ballot we need serious help yikes wow
you got to run yep someone's got to pick
up that mantle you
know let's see cha says this isn't that
difficult remove Biden from the ballots
in red States as for these partisan hack
judges start filing madeup charges
against their kids and family members
issue arrest warrants and hold them
without bail I I think you misunderstand
see this is the I'm sorry I got to throw
a little criticism your way this is what
Republicans don't understand you don't
need to make up
charges show me the men and I'll show
you the crime right if they want to play
this game with Trump and and issue
summary summary judgments without
evidence yeah you don't make up charges
you actually just then go and enforce
the law against these Democrats which is
not being
done Buster Rucka says Tim your argument
doesn't make sense if they used a
constitutional Clause to ban him then
they made it a federal matter so scotus
now has Authority incorrect that is not
true how a state supreme court
interprets how they decide to run their
elections does not give the federal
government the authority and like I said
there will be citation of the 9th and
10th amendments basically it's if it's
not prohibited the states can do it so
the federal government the argument
would have to be scotus has the
authority to overrule a private
organization's electoral voting Pro vot
voting processes I'm not convinced they
can now the Supreme Court could argue
that the political parties act as defa
deao public institutions despite being
private organizations therefore they
will issue that ruling nothing you knew
about it okay totally fair but I think
there's a strong
possibility a right- leaning Court says
we can't tell a private organization who
to put in charge yeah how to run an
election if it was the general election
being run by the state we could issue an
argument however the Constitution also
says State legislatures have final say
and how their elections are run the
Supreme Court might even come back and
be like states are to be run as their
state determines that's why we rejected
Texas b v Pennsylvania yeah Texas sued
Pennsylvania Supreme Court said screw
off we don't care Trump might file an
appeal and they might say we have no
interest in adjudicating a private
organization's rule process we're not
going to we're not going to have a
supreme court hearing on on how
Starbucks chooses the president of the
company why would we have a ruling on
how uh uh Colorado's Republican party a
private organization does we'll see we
will see
man I think it might just be crazy and
you might only get Trump and Biden are
off of every
ballot who knows yeah
ghost candidates there's no election
because they just removed everybody that
was possibly running
yeah Anthony bird says Mr Kent proudly
voted and donated to you in the last
election can't wait to vote for you next
year we lost what is it uh uh Klickitat
County before the last election how will
you win over Vancouver you have the aial
vote yeah so we did really well in the
rural counties we just kind of lost in
our Urban Hub Vancouver which is kind of
right across the river from Portland um
we right now are working on unifying the
Republican party because we had that
hardfought primary and so I had a lot of
Republicans who voted up and down ballot
Republican but they didn't vote for me
because of the we have a late primary
too it's in August so they mailed the
ballots out about five weeks later I
spent all my money trying to get through
the primary 14 million spent against me
and so I had zero money going into the
general election the Democrats wisely
Consolidated around one candidate and
then hit me on day one of $6 million my
Democrat opponent basically ran as a
moderate as well so we're exposing her
voting record which is the same record
as Pelosi and AOC and so already had a
lot of good Unity this time but yeah I
appreciate the appreciate the
support Mr denic dtic says AZ would
never stay loyal to the
feds yeah perhaps
perhaps Raymond Stanley Jr says dang Tim
really thought about that Civil War map
I mean for a couple minutes we were
talking about it before the show but
yeah like the uh red States would be
would be cut through the middle by uh uh
you know you wouldn't just see a north
and a South that map actually makes
sense when you look at like the Spanish
Civil War or the Syrian Civil War
various factions pop up in various areas
and then they are are aligned or aren't
aligned who knows
man it'll be it'll be crazy Jennifer sui
says Colorado plus 14 States plus DC
give National popular vote their elector
electoral votes 196 out of 260 electoral
votes why doesn't anybody talk about
this imagine if we could rally
disaffected voters across the country
and make their vote count we do talk
about the Electoral National electoral
vote Coalition or whatever it's called
and this is their plan to make it so
that you can never have an election and
that they will always just give the vote
to the Democrat great not interested in
that although it could backfire because
the national vote coalition's argument
is whoever whoever wins the national
popular vote will get their State's
electoral votes which means California
could go Republican it's real simple
California's not going Republican it's
two to1 Democrat but if they join this
Coalition and the Republican does win by
a thin margin in the popular vote all of
those electoral votes from California go
to the Republican instead now why would
you do that yeah I don't know I suppose
they'd like to let them do it all right
we'll grab uh we'll grab one more down
here still piss says best skate shoe of
all time SXL Vans era or Adidas uh
businet
busen uh I don't agree with either of
those
I would say one of my favorite shoes was
the America bevel but you had to shooo
the uh uh the toe cap before skating it
because those old school caps they were
the stupidest construction now I've been
skating the I think what Kyle Walkers
yeah I just have like 20 pairs of these
because they're just so good really
really good yeah the KY Walker vans so
uh there you go thanks for the question
uh all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends but more
importantly
go to timcast.net
is really really great considering we're
only on uh day three we didn't have a
big promotion yester you know we try to
push as hard as we can but um I'm we hit
number one on iTunes instantly and so I
think I think we're we're doing fairly
well but uh we'd like to do really well
so with your support we need each and
everybody uh who who supports the work
of Michael nolles and Jeremy uh Jeremy
boring as well as Tim Cass to spend the
69 cents but I'll tell you what you'll
also get 35% off all Cas brew coffee
that means if you're buying for 69 cents
you can order 100 bucks of coffee and
get $35 off and it's Christmas so maybe
you want to buy some fresh roasted
coffee for Christmas send it to your
families or whatever get that discount
code uh we'll see you over at
timcast.net
campaign I don't take any corporate pack
money so please go to Joe Kent for
congress.com to do that and uh thanks
for having me Tim right on I am Phil
that remains on X I'm Phil that remains
official on Instagram the band is all it
remains you can follow us on Spotify on
Apple music on Pandora on Amazon music
on YouTube you know the
internet it was good to be here uh i'
recommend going and watching the Joe
Kent interview that I did with Clair
brimo uh I think I believe it was a
culture War episode yeah and you got
really deep into like what you're going
through with your campaigns and and your
area so go check that out I'm shanman on
Instagram and Twitter and I'm a writer
for scanner.com SC cnr.com
and uh I'm surge.com um very fun to be
in Phoenix uh hope you guys enjoyed the
show and uh yeah let's get to the after
show we'll see you all over at
timcast.net